bachelor Nick vial opens up about the  next Bachelorette  [Music]  ladies and gentlemen please welcome our  next Bachelorette Rachael Lindsey  bachelor contestant Rachael Lindsey was  announced as the new Bachelorette on  Monday night's Jimmy Kimmel Live and  current bachelor Nick vile opened up to  Ellen DeGeneres on The Ellen Show airing  Tuesday about his excitement for his  former flame I'm very excited for her I  think she's going to be an amazing  Bachelorette Monday night he also  tweeted about the news saying Rachael is  beauty and class we haven't seen how the  31 year old attorney and Knicks love  connection ends yet she's still a  contestant on his season airing now the  36 year old bachelor played coolly about  who he does choose in the end look at  your eyes I think he picked Corinth okay  and whether he's actually found at love  this time around are you in love maybe  [Music]  you